المحور الاصعب
ذاك تشخيص الرئيس الاوكراني لجبهه بخموت
التي يحتدم فيها القتال بين قوات بلاده
وميليشيا فاجنر مؤسس الميليشيا تحدث عن
تعزيزات اوكرانيه ترسل للمدينه التي تزداد
المعارك فيها دمويه وفق قوله
الجيش الاوكراني يرسل جنودا اضافيين الى
باخمت عشرات الالاف من الجنود الاوكرانيين
يقاومون بغضب ودمويه المعارك تزداد يوما
بعد يوم
وفق موقع ريبار العسكري الموالي لروسيا
تقدم مقاتلوا فاجنر في الجبهه الشماليه
الغربيه للمدينه باتجاه خروموفا اخر طرق
امداد الجيش الاوكراني
وتقدمت فاجنر ايضا من جهه الشرق حتى
اقتربت من نهر باخمت وفي الوقت نفسه تحاول
مواصله التقدم من الجنوب لاكمال تطويق
المدينه
بالمقابل سبق ان اعلنت قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه صد خمسه وثمانين هجوما روسيا
على جميع المحاور في بخمت واصفه الوضع
بالصعب والمتوتر وهو ما جعل فكره الانسحاب
الاوكراني من المدينه مطروحه كما نقل عن
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني لكن سرعان ما
خرجت نائبه وزير الدفاع متحدثه عن خسائر
من وصفتهم بالمحتلين وعن احباط القوات
الروسيه ومؤكده التمسك باستعاده السيطره
على المدينه
وقرار تمسك ببخ قرار استراتيجي وليس
سياسيا يتخذه العسكريون الذين لا توجههم
الدوافع السياسيه
هي الجهه الاسخن لكنها ليست الوحيده
بالطبع تتحدث القوات المواليه لروسيا في
دونيتس عن قصف اوكراني على احياء سكنيه
خلف خسائر بشريه واضرارا في المباني
والبنيه التحتيه والى الجنوب هاجمت
اوكرانيا بكثافه شبه جزيره القرم وقالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها احبطت ذلك
الهجوم دون خسائر
بطائرات مسيره على منشات في شبه جزيره
القرم من قبل نظام كييف واسقطت انظمه
الدفاع الجوي 6 مسيرات هجوميه اوكرانيه
وتم تعطيل اربع مسيرات اخرى من قبل وسائط
الحرب الالكترونيه
بالمقابل يتحدث الجيش الاوكراني عن مضاعفه
روسيا عدد سفونها في البحر الاسود الى
سبعه عشره سفينه منها خمس حاملات صواريخ
وغواصتان وفق ما نقلته وسائل اعلام محليه
عن القياده الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]